hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
and in this video i'm going to be
talking once again about capital gains
tax
and in this video i'm going to give you
the three things you can do
to pay zero non-capital gains tax
everyone's talking about capital gains
tax at the moment because
the government are talking about
increasing capital gains tax in fact
they're talking about doubling it okay
at the moment it's around about 28
and they're talking about bringing you
up to closer to 40 or beyond
no one knows for sure what's going to
happen but i want to talk about the
three ways you can avoid paying any
capital gains tax
i recently did a video about what i
think the government are doing
why i think they're doing it how they're
scaremongering to try and sell
more houses and shift more stock right
now because there's too many buyers and
not enough houses on the market
that's a whole other story if you want
to check that video out i'll leave it in
the card and also in the description
to this video but right now these are
the three ways to pay zero capital gains
tax
first thing you should do though before
you worry about capital gains tax the
most important thing you need to really
worry about right now
is smashing the like button to this
video okay so smash the like button do
me a favor i put out a new video every
single day
also subscribe turn the notification
bell on number one
if you live in a property
and it's your residence and then you
sell it
you pay zero capital gains tax
so capital gains tax by the way is a tax
that you pay on
profit on a property so you you buy a
property it goes up in value you then
sell it
that profit you pay capital gains tax if
you've lived in it
if it's your resident address you don't
pay capital gains
tax so if you're considering the
fix and flip strategy i.e buying houses
to do them up and sell them it might be
worth
moving into them doing them up and
selling them
and then the profit you don't pay tax on
how cool
is that that's the first way there's two
more ways
second way to not pay capital gains tax
is
when you fix the property up and it goes
up in value
or if it just goes up in value over time
instead of selling it
re-mortgage the property you're gonna
any equity that you release from the
house because you've got a new mortgage
you're basically borrowing
against the house you're using the
equity the uplift
as collateral to borrow money
against that house but when you
refinance it the money that you take out
you can reinvest into more properties
how much tax are you going gonna pay on
that none
no tax because you can't be taxed on
debt
so it's a way of leveraging money
pulling equity and profits out of
properties
this is the brr strategy buy refurbish
refinance rent then you just leave the
house
rent it out it's giving you a nice
income and you're going to use the
equity to put down on another house what
are you going to do you're going to
refurbish it
then you're going to refinance and pull
the actually out of that one and you can
recycle your money again and again and
again
the third strategy that you can pay zero
capital gains tax is to buy
your property and buy it through a
company if you buy it through a limited
company
and then you sell it like like you
probably saw i did it on youtube
um i've done quite a few fix and flips
i've done the uh the bell houses from
scratch and sold them and all kinds of
different things
if you do that through a company even if
it's not your company even if it's a
part of a joint venture
but if you do it through a company you
won't pay any capital gains tax either
now you will have to pay tax you're
going to pay corporation tax but it's
way
less than capital gains tax corporation
tax is around about 19
might go up a little bit but it's still
considerably less
than capital gains tax so you'll pay no
capital gains tax if you live in it
if you buy it through a company and sell
it that way you'll pay corporation tax
instead which is less
or if you refinance it instead of
selling it i hope you found this video
helpful
i am not a tax advisor by the way i can
only speak from experience
so i would suggest if you're wanting to
save on tax to get
qualified advice from an accountant
because i am not that what i am is i'm a
very successful property investor but i
can only speak from experience
so if you found the video helpful drop
me a like
drop a comment below and i look forward
to seeing you in the next uh
tomorrow the next video do a video every
single day if you want to see the last
video i did about why i think that
they're
increasing capital gains tax check out
this video right here you'll find that
really helpful
also don't forget to subscribe over here
and i'll see you next time thanks